everybody plays a beautiful game loving
zookas it's all they don't want it and
it's all she wants to but you ought to
play the beautiful Gayle I'm Raziel I
wanna make
but you wanna marry me
yeah well Dex is with us now and I was
looking on your Twitter site today and
you've got the slogan up there Sepp
Blatter don't matter
yeah I'm always changing that well how
do you feel now that he's gone and it's
a good thing I guess I mean this this is
successful football this is what I was
kind of it's what I wanted to achieve it
didn't really I mean I didn't achieve it
but well I'm sure you know a lot of
people I mean why did you why did you
write that song what inspired you and I
wrote it around the time the World Cup
last year and it's about a year ago it
was just sort of my mind at the time I
was writing it and I just sort of was
thinking about the bad side of it safer
and football as a whole in the world at
the moment what's particularly struck
you about that about the bad side of
okay just as well especially with the
software in Brazil just how a sort of
country which is sort of terribly poor
in some places and terribly rich in
others and people who are the headed
giant corporations could come in make
loads of money for the rich people in
the form of the World Cup and the
Olympics and leave the rest of them I
thought I need to subject matter Bernie
songwriter where'd you get your
inspiration from oh so I mean when
there's not really much going on that
and my life will generally look UCSC's
go oh yeah yeah but you can't really
write about maths exams and stuff so I
generally would go along the lines of
what's in the news what what I'm what
I'm thinking about what what I want
people to talk about what I want people
to hear for me and what I want people to
know that my views are and I'll make
that clear and you do words out music
yeah yeah yeah that was almost like
Britain funding I never had an awful lot
of people hearing from you because
amongst other things you would play a
blast and break or something yeah tell
us about that how that comes back um
well a while ago before sort of
everything kicked off at the center to
Glastonbury emerging talent competition
to really think much of it and then um
guys from cracking the road picked it up
and put me through and then
saint-lo started paying my stuff and
Phil Taggart and then just sort of built
up momentum got in won the competition
and getting to play Glastonbury gonna be
re-released in Brazil around that time
too so yeah vicious right where do you
play typically are you to yoga and pubs
and clubs okay I've done I've done a few
sort of club night gigs and stuff where
I'm able to get in I've done a load of
gigs not I've done many this year just
sort of been preparing for the summer
really it's sorting stuff out with all
the sort of attention have been okay I
see a lot of attention having to do if
there's reports of labels fighting over
you you'll be able to a kind of thing
about what you'd be kicked in yeah it's
weird I mean we're basically we're
planning to move for the delay black
Glastonbury the sign there at some know
what happened really who's your manager
surrounded Tara Rob she is somewhere
here and yeah she's been helping me out
a lot with that just dealing with all
the label people I can kind of how would
you feel a sense obviously you haven't
done it yet but I mean it's bit like
football isn't it I mean if you make it
that's going to be a lot of big money
there as well I mean is it it's a weird
weird thought that all this has come off
the back of one song because it never
happens you never really get any kind of
adventure that the back of one's self so
it was supposed to real particulars you
say you're in the middle of GCSEs things
feel somewhat irrelevant when you don't
want restful I mean yeah when you've got
when you're working in sort of with
people in the music industry and need
10% of any form of degree and anything
kind of grades it's not exactly
inspiring but so you guys want to carry
on with with both in parallel tea yeah I
mean you know I want to be a musician
and well I'd and the musician I want to
do well with music and but you know I'm
gonna keep doing exams cuz yeah